donc là comme on pouvait voir vous avez
une fissure traversante au niveau de la
terrasse donc qui sait la terrasse qui
s'est coupée en deux en fait et qui
s'est effondré sur la partie droite de 5
cm c'est ce qu'a découvert la famille
robin en rentrant de vacances la fine
fissures apparues en juillet est devenue
grande
pour nathalie robin c'est la conséquence
du trop-plein de pluie suivi de la
sécheresse qui met à mal son terrain
argileux
on a vu des failles assez impressionnant
c'est vraiment la sécheresse un peu
moins visible maintenant parce que la
pluie a offert un mini fier de terrain
donc du coup c'est en train de se
combler
mais voilà on sait que ça joue beaucoup
donc on attend vraiment de voir comment
ça va évoluer quoi en neuf ans la
famille avait observé ce genre de
fissures dans le jardin mais jamais sur
le bâti à ce stade la facture de remise
en état de la terrasse s'élève à
plusieurs milliers de rouges et les
robes en ont peur que les frais ne
s'alourdisse on est vraiment dans le
flou total pour l'instant parce qu'on
est vraiment en plein dedans et je vous
dis l'écartement s'est provoquée fin
s'est produit au mois de juillet mais le
l'effondrement de la partie droite de la
terrasse et en plat on est en plein
dedans là donc ça fait trois semaines
que ça tombe à vitesse assez
impressionnante donc on ne sait pas où
ça va s'arrêter pour l'instant la maison
n'a pas été fragilisées contrairement à
certains voisins ou la véranda se
désolidarise du bâtiment avant même de
voir l'étendue définitif des dégâts
les robins vont demander la
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pour l'instant trois dossiers
similaires ont été déposées à la mairie
de villandry